and one of the greatest kids
mtv you got slimed that's nickelodeon
scarlett johansson gets slimed by
husband colin jost
mid acceptance speech
don't don't don't touch don't don't
touch me not don't let me
it's really no let me get it
i love you where did you even get this
amazon pre-slime scarjo virtually
accepted the generation award at the mtv
movie and tv awards on sunday night
thank you so much to my fans
for riding the wave with me and for
supporting
my career so i can continue to have the
good fortune to pursue the job
that is my passion and i realize what an
absolute gift it is to be able
to have the opportunity to do what i
love
everything she does is just with such
poise and grace and she's so articulate
and
and just a fantastic talented actress
and i look up to her a lot so
i think it's well deserved i think
everybody's just been following her
career
since she was so young and to see her
kind of
make the brave choices that you know a
lot of people
are scared to so um full deserved and
and i think she's gonna play even
greater characters
i've had a long time crush on scar joe
so you know to see her accept an award
like that and
you know just to be honored for her work
i mean it's it's such an incredible
moment so congrats to her
as a gift to her fans scarlett also
brought along a brand new sneak peek of
her upcoming
marvel flick black widow please enjoy
this exclusive clip from
black widow
okay anytime though shut up
[Music]
[Music]
okay you got a plan or should i just
stay dug and go my plan was to drive us
away
gloria plan sucks
you're welcome